sur le front sud les soldats Ukrainiens
sont à l'offensive les positions de
cette unité postées en lisière de la
région de Kerson reste ciblé tous les
jours
ils ont commencé à tirer ici hier avec
des tanks
il y a eu
7-80
les arbres aussi il y a eu des éclats
partout
la seule manière de se protéger ici
c'est de s'enterrer
ses positions mais nos hommes sont
malins la contre-offensive est en cours
il nous gave sont déjà loin dans la
région de Herson
ces hommes sont d'autant plus motivés
que la plupart sont originaires de la
région il progresse vers ce qu'ils ont
dû quitter
j'ai été tellement choqué quand ils sont
arrivés chez moi dans mon village dans
ma région
[Musique]
mon âme est heureuse parce qu'en ce
moment même nos soldats avancent vers
mon village
si les soldats Ukrainiens enregistrent
des progrès rapides sur ce front sud
pilonné par l'armée russe c'est en
partie grâce aussi ville qui renseigne
l'armée
je vais être Lana n'a jamais quitté son
village situé sur la ligne de front peu
importe qu'il faille vivre en souterrain
et peu importe les tirs
je vais être Lana a fait partie de ce
que l'on appelle les partisans ces
résistants qui aident
leurs paroles est extrêmement rare elle
témoigne car elle estime que les Russes
ne reviendront plus dans son village
on a formé un groupe pour patrouiller on
avait 26 hommes dans ce que je trouve et
grimper en haut des immeubles avec des
jumelles et ils observaient ils
regardaient les mouvements des colonnes
il les rapportait à l'armée qui
bombardait ensuite
au début il n'y avait pas beaucoup de
renseignements donc on est des beaucoup
plus les militaires ont donné la
position de tous les convois
ceci dit très récemment dégâts encore
actifs ont appelé ils m'ont signalé
qu'ils avaient repéré une position
importante et j'ai immédiatement appelé
les militaires pour leur passer
l'information
je vais être Lana a été blessée par un
tir de temps crus en allant repérer une
position ennemie ce n'est tout de même
pas ça dit-elle qui allait m'arrêter